brain is capable of anything but if you
leave it uncontrolled its tendency its
instinct is to look for what's wrong
before he went into the operating room i
promise you the highest point of my life
and then
four hours later ali is gone my new
baseline of happiness in life has gone
from here to here and you can make a
choice to stay here or you can make a
choice to make it slightly better and
that incremental bit is within the hands
of every one of us happiness is mixed up
in our modern world with so many weapons
of mass destruction as i call them joy
pleasure fun entertainment elation
excitement and a lot of ego but that's
not happiness that's not genuine
happiness and my answer my only answer
and i actually ask our listeners and you
to tell me i'm wrong is i
hey friends and welcome back to deep
dive my name is ali and each week i have
the immense pleasure to sit down with
authors creators entrepreneurs and other
inspiring people and we talk about how
they got to where they are and some of
the principles strategies and tools that
can help us along our shared journey of
trying to live our best lives now mohs
had a pretty interesting background in
that he used to be the chief business
officer of google x which is like the
moonshot division of google where they
do like a weird and wacky and wonderful
project and he got there after spending
30 years of his career in tech working
at microsoft and other such big
companies but then in 2014 a tragic
event happened that really shook
everything about moe's life to its core
and that was that his son ali who was
just 21 at the time ended up getting
appendicitis and then because of various
medical errors during the appendectomy
the removal of the appendix
ali tragically and sadly lost his life
now it's hard to imagine the impact that
losing a son has on a family but that
incident caused mo to basically
re-evaluate his life and transfer
transition his mission from
kind of getting involved in bit 10 big
tech and making all this money towards
trying to help one billion people become
happier which sort of became his mission
um because that was what his son ali was
all about for me this was one of my
favorite episodes of the podcast i feel
like i learned so much and i got a
master class in
happiness in control of the ego in
emotions and we talked a lot about how
to play the infinite game of life and
what is really the point of all of this
stuff we kind of touched a little bit on
moe's new book that little voice in your
head which kind of talks about the sub
routines that we have running in our
mind that cause us to be distressed or
sad or unhappy anyway i really hope you
enjoy this conversation with mo gaudat
all right well thank you so much for
coming on here i'm very very very happy
to be here thank you so much so fun and
it's it's it's nice hearing hearing your
voice in person because i've been
hearing your voice on the audio book
yeah yeah
so the thing about that audio book is
that most people will say i know you
like i've i've had you in my yeah i have
had you in my ears for like 11 hours
it's a very intimate experience it
really is having someone in just in your
airpods in your headphones for a long
time yeah i think that audiobook when it
was recorded
uh it was literally the first time so so
i i wrote the book two and a half years
before it came out oh and yeah and and
then editors wanted to change it and it
was very precious for me because it was
ali's story yeah and anyway so
eventually when it came out and as i was
reading the audiobook it was the very
first time that i read any of the
paragraphs i wrote about ali because
these were never edited every every
editor i worked with five editors
every editor was like yep i'm happy with
that right
and so it was very emotional when i read
them because i didn't know about them
for two and a half years yeah and yeah
and so it made me
made the book um
very personal i think yeah yeah that
that really came through because when i
was listening i remember listening to
the introduction it really kind of
brought me to tears i was like
i've never been i've never been brought
to tears by an audiobook before but it
was it was just fantastic um
the the production was really the shock
yeah
you know
so dealing with dealing with the loss of
a child is
and a lifetime i think of uh of uh
of grief it you know of course you can
find peace you can find contentment but
to find uh to get rid of the pain i
think is impossible so there is always a
tiny bit of pain when i wrote the
introduction i was pouring my heart out
because my son had been gone for 17 days
right that was it
then i read it again two and a half
years later and it's just
yeah exploded me i think i i also cried
on the introduction myself and and um
and i had this incredible uh um producer
of the audiobook who would tell me oh no
no no it's fine mo we remove those parts
read it again right and then he took the
parts that i was crying and put them on
the audiobook i was like okay that's
yeah a bit of a you know deceit here but
anyway yeah
wow yeah i i i can imagine kind of then
reading it two and a half years later
would have kind of brought back up a lot
of the memories and yeah yeah i mean
for me every time i remember ali is a
beautiful memory as much as it is a
little bit of a pain
more and more by the way i think it's
it's more
i think there was a point around a year
after he left us where i realized
something that completely flipped my
view of everything which was
yes ali died but ali also lived and and
you see the interesting part about us
humans is that we never really
you know everything that we were given
we take for granted
it's like in reality we never planned
for him to come my wife and i were not
expecting kids ali just happened right
and and he comes into our life and he
enriches our life so much for 21 and a
half years
and then he leaves and the typical human
mind will say how good how could life
take my son
but the typical human mind would forget
how could life has have given me my son
right and it's so interesting when you
realize that that
honestly if if i was given a choice
with all the pain i left i felt when he
left us
if i would avoid the pain by not having
him absolutely not i'll take the pain 10
times
you know just to have him in my life and
so
when you do when you don't take those
things for granted
suddenly you realize that i'm so blessed
even with the pain of leaving him i'm so
blessed that i had him
yeah and and you just look at the rest
of our lives ali it's it's you know
it's
it we have so much we have so much in
our lives and if anyone listening to us
now just considers the fact
that they have a device
you know that connects to the entire
world of information that they can come
and join us in this conversation that
this device is in full color with high
speed internet that they can click away
from what they like and not like they
have safety and a roof on top of their
heads obviously
because if they didn't they wouldn't
have the time to watch this right yeah
and when you or listen to this and when
you when you really think about it
all of those blessings you know in
places like ukraine today or in syria or
in palestine or in yemen or in so many
places around the world these things are
not taken for granted
and when you see it that way you
suddenly say oh my god my life is so
blessed
even with the pain that's in it because
there's always going to be pain in life
it's it's just an amazing life yeah wow
that's i i think
stuff like that like just appreciating
the blessings that we have
it's it's one of those things that is is
almost a cliche but like i think it's
cliche for a reason because
it just is so true it is it's it is
really battling
your uh instinct of the negativity bias
okay
interestingly your brain is capable of
anything i mean my new book is exactly
about that it's exactly about your brain
being able to uh to do anything what
what you tell it to do right but if you
leave it uncontrolled
its tendency its instinct is to look for
what's wrong
why because it's a it's a survival
machine yes it is there for the simple
reason of detecting if there is a tiger
so it can protect you okay and yes if
there are no tigers it can go on and
invent iphones but but you know if but
it's still even as it's inventing
iphones trying to detect everything it's
my boss annoying is my you know
boyfriend girlfriend
you know trying to leave me or you know
am i going to starve whatever right
but that's until you take charge if you
take charge you know that little voice
in your head i basically say it's like
your computer it's like your device you
can tell it what to do and it will do it
and once you start to take charge
that machine can be instructed to look
for what's right
and when you look for what's right my my
claim i have no scientific evidence
behind it that 99.9 percent of your life
is right
okay whoever you are i you know i have
you know i have a tiny bit of a sore
throat today but that happens to me
twice a year
most of the year my my voice is okay
right you know
you you most of us live our entire life
on solid ground
most of us never ever see an earthquake
right ever unless it's in the news
and even if you do it's like once or
twice in your lifetime it the baseline
of life is okay yeah and then and then
the negatives
just happen you know their dips out of
okay and then back to the baseline right
and and when you see that then it's only
fair to instruct your brain if you want
to see the truth if you want to
acknowledge the truth of your life it's
only fair to instruct your brain to
look for 99 percent 99.9 as i say of
good things so i have i have this very
simple exercise when my brain tells me
something wrong about anything okay okay
i ask for nine other good things about
the situation ah nice so so you know
when i when i
uh
um you know arrived downstairs and
because you were so generous to send a
car to bring me here i didn't actually
have the address so i didn't know where
to go right the first thing that my
brain tells me is oops oh but they were
so kind to give to send me a car but
there is you know it's sunny and it's
not raining but you know there's this
beautiful cafe that the downstairs that
i need to try later but i have your
number so i can text you and say hey i'm
downstairs and end end and end if i
focus on all of these then it's amazing
thank you so much for not putting the
address in
the in in the calendar right
and if you focus on ah but things need
to be perfect how come how come you know
my team didn't
you know find that point i can make
myself miserable the event is exactly
the same but it's my choice
to look at it as a wonderful event or as
a negative event
one of the things that i
i found interesting um is that you often
say that happiness is a choice totally a
choice and you also often say that
saying that is very controversial and it
loses you or whatever percentage of
podcast listeners who don't want to
believe that happiness is a choice it
loses me exactly eight percent if my
statistics are correct eight yeah oh
nice
i'll tell you why you know when i wrote
when i wrote solve for happy the first
time
i uh i basically wrote it like we write
software i i created a beta version put
it online
invited people to come and read it
literally on google docs i would invite
them to walk in and edit my my words
which was an amazing experience 270
people to be exact and you know i asked
them to do a little survey to tell me a
little bit about themselves before that
and because it's on docs you can
actually follow how the readers are
progressing
and i lost eight percent of my readers
on page 11
okay and page 11 was the page where i
said happiness is a choice
and and it's obvious because for so many
people
being the victim
is a very interesting place to be
interesting yeah it's because of course
there is
value to being the victim okay so
remember a lot of what we are as humans
comes from when you were younger so as a
two-year-old you you know how you
sometimes i know you did sometimes you
would go like mommy
and you pretend to cry oh yeah right why
would you pretend to cry because crying
allowed your mom to go like okay baby
something's wrong either you know tap
you on the back or remove whatever was
annoying you or whatever just give you
attention yeah so there is a utility to
that and for some reason as i i always
say most of our problems with happiness
are because some of us decided not to
grow beyond sex
oh okay okay yeah so so you know after a
while you start to tell yourself there's
no utility to that there isn't you know
i i can actually get up myself
and get the nutella jar that i wanted i
don't have to wait for mommy anymore why
am i crying yeah right or i can actually
take charge of my life
you know if life is a little challenging
i can cry for mommy but mommy is not
going to show up if my boss is annoying
and and when you're stuck in that space
for some of us there is a utility of i'm
the victim which means i have no
responsibility for my unhappiness okay
it's life life is treating me bad no
life is treating everyone bad
occasionally right or you know um i
don't have to really go out of my way to
do my homework to be happy or to do my
homework to be fit or to do my homework
to you know to make my relationship work
well and there is an interesting comfort
in that
it's like i'm i'm
you know i don't need to do anything
about it because there is nothing to be
done about it it's the responsibility of
life and not me yeah but that's not true
happiness is a choice and it's you know
i always tell people the simplest way to
understand that is you can obsess about
the comment your partner told you
all through your commute to work okay
and the minute you get to work your boss
says you know where is the report we
asked for or you have to be in a meeting
and what do you do you tell your brain
okay brain that's it we can't think
about this for now focus on the meeting
and throughout the meeting you're okay
throughout the meeting you're sitting
there you're listening at them
attentively and you're not thinking
about this issue you're probably
thinking about how boring the meeting is
yeah but you're not unhappy about that
issue at all the minute you walk out of
the meeting you're gonna you go like
okay but my partner said this on friday
let's play it again it's a choice yeah
and i i i hosted on slo-mo on on my
podcast i hosted uh dr jill balti taylor
which is definitely one of my favorite
humans on the planet so jill is a
neuroscientist
and
she
analyzes the brain's relationship with
unhappiness i i refer to her a lot in in
my book
and
she her studies will show you that
from the time take any negative emotion
take anger for example from the time an
event triggers you
to the time you're flooded with stress
hormones to the time you take a reaction
or you don't to the time the hormones
are flooded out of your body is 90
seconds
that's it you can't hold your anger that
that over
physiological response is 90 seconds so
i asked her and i said so jill what does
that mean why why do people stay angry
for years and she said they regenerated
every 90 seconds
so so every 90 seconds you have the
ability to say your your body is saying
okay here is a buffer do you need me to
be is there still a threat should i
still be stressed okay and you go like
yeah but my partner said this and you
get angry again and again and again for
90 seconds and for most of us we're so
creative so you know your partner says
something hurtful on a friday on
saturday you say he must be cheating on
me on sunday you say all the things i do
for them but you know they do they don't
do for me you and you can make it much
worse we're very very creative every 90
seconds and that's why we stay unhappy
that's why we stay angry
yeah that's that's really interesting i
i don't come across the 92nd thing
before but i think that's like this this
idea that you know in between stimulus
and response exactly there is a gap
absolutely and that's the gap that we in
which we can choose a response
absolutely it's an idea like for example
the stoics i've been talking about for
ages as well and it's it's cool how
modern science is now showing this to be
true okay a few a few questions on this
point the the first one is
so obviously i'm also on board with this
idea that happiness is a choice but any
time i say that i feel a niggling part
of myself because i know that some
people will be thinking
what about
child abuse what about depression what
about clinical anxiety what about
posttraumatic stress disorder what about
all these other extreme things
is it really fair to say happiness is a
choice
is that like just telling a depressed
person to cheer up
um and i've never quite been able to
answer that sorry that's a great
question by the way so absolute
happiness is not a choice
nobody's ever always happy
okay i had the joy of spending an hour
and a half with his holiness the dalai
lama i i know most of the top monks in
the world who have practiced for 40 50
60 years i mean someone like matthieuric
hard which again is a very dear friend
and i hosted on slo-mo is a person that
is
done 60 000 hours of meditation of
lifetime meditation okay and i asked him
and i said matthew are you always happy
and he said of course not i'm always
pissed off
okay and he and he and he's very open
about it it's like he's the state of the
world if you have compassion
makes you feel a negative emotions
of course if you have chronic pain if
you have been subjected to abuse
if you've lost someone that you love
it is it's not the same
uh ease
of finding happiness
that then like if you went wanted to buy
a sandwich and your place was closed you
know your favorite or they didn't have
your favorite sandwich some of us feel
unhappy about that and it's absolutely a
choice not to right it's not comparable
to i've been abused
the question is
in relative terms
in relative terms which is which which
is what matters losing my child could
make me miserable
nobody would blame me for that
but also in relative terms from that new
low point of my life
so ali ali my son died because of a
medical error you know basically they
made a mistake in a very simple five
mistakes in a very simple surgical
operation
now
i hugged him before he went into the
operating room i promise you the highest
point of my life okay he was handsome he
was tall he was strong he was every
father's dream
and then
four hours later ali is gone
four hours later my new baseline of
happiness in life has gone from here to
here
and you can make a choice to stay here
or you can make a choice to make it
slightly better and slightly better and
slightly better
yeah i may never return back to that
high point i may never return back to a
place of absolute happiness of you know
remembering my son and not missing him
but i have the choice to make that
incremental bit and that incremental bit
is within the hands of every one of us
and that incremental bit interestingly
is the wise choice because isn't it bad
enough to have been abused isn't it
isn't it bad enough that you broke up
isn't it bad enough that you lost
someone that you love
do you want to stay there or do you want
to make the choice to make it slightly
better
and i think that still counts as a
choice even if it doesn't get you to
absolute happiness which nobody is ever
at it still counts as a choice got it so
it's like we're saying
i i guess people's immediate objection
to happiness is a choice sounds like
well i can't be happy all the time the
happiness that i have when playing video
games with my friends
obviously is not the happiness i can
have
when i'm depressed for whatever reason
but what we're saying is that like
becoming a little happier in whatever
situation that you're in here is a
choice happier isn't true less unhappy
is a choice by the way happiness when
you're playing video games is not
happiness
okay so so so the the most important
part of the definition is what is
happiness what am i talking about right
because because happiness is mixed up in
our modern world with so many weapons of
mass destruction as i call them okay
basically the idea is i can't sell you
happiness why can i not sell you
happiness because you're born happy
the the the every child you've ever seen
if they have their basic needs they're
happy you just make us a child safe and
and loved and you know make the warm the
room warm enough and don't shout next to
the child and the child is giggling and
playing with its toes right it's our
innate state it's our default set
so i can't sell you that
the the the the
what the modern world tries to sell you
is
uh
joy pleasure fun entertainment elation
excitement that this is what they're
selling you and a lot of ego this is
what they're selling you but but that's
not happiness that's not genuine
happiness genuine happiness is that calm
and peaceful contentment you feel when
you're okay with life as it is
doesn't matter what life is but when
you're okay with it
that's that's the feeling we look for
this is the feeling you feel when you're
sitting on a little river
somewhere in the middle of nature
and
and you're you know you don't have
access to to your phone or to data
network so no bosses emails and no
bosses phone calls and no no instagram
posts to annoy you and right and what's
your state then you have that calm and
peace and you tell yourself i wish i can
stay here longer now that in my
definition that calm and peaceful
contentment that's what happiness is you
can add to it excitement you can add to
it pleasure you can add to it fun you
can add to it elation right you can you
can go and play a video game with your
friends and
on top of that calmness you're you have
fun too
right but then if you start from fun the
problem is it becomes very
uh transient the minute you stop playing
video games you start to go back to
think about what your partner said on
friday
and you end up in a place where you're
unhappy again your brain just goes
through it and and and this is reflected
very very clearly in our biology right
so in our biology that state of calm and
peaceful contentment is when your
sympathetic parasympathetic nervous
system is engaged right so
you're you're supposed to have two modes
of operation as a machine as a human
machine for survival
one of them is in a state of stress
fight or flight or freeze and that
you're flooded with hormones stress
hormones and you're trying to become
superhuman to escape a threat or to deal
with a challenge that that state
has is important for your survival
it's also complemented with another
state when the tiger has run away or you
managed to escape it or you beat it in
the nose and the tiger fell down or
whatever you did heroically
you're you're in a you're in a state now
where all of the adrenaline rushes out
of your body all of your cortisol
flushes away and you sit back
to do what
to do to to do the opposite of that
state in that state
your stomach stops to digest food
your all of your blood is directed to
your muscles and your brain and to your
eyesight you no longer have the ability
to do other
important critical functions properly so
when you're in carmen peace
what is happening really is you're
you're being told i need that other time
to digest my food to rest my body to
replenish my muscles to reflect to sleep
and so on now when we define happiness
as that calm and peaceful contentment
when you're in that state your body is
actually flooded with serotonin and
serotonin
even though the the internet will tell
you that there are four happiness
hormones no my view is that the only
happiness hormone is serotonin is that
calm and peaceful contentment and
serotonin actually is a calmer it
basically tells your body everything's
safe okay i've scanned yeah i've scanned
the world around me hold it rest relax
you know
enjoy the calm enjoy the quiet
fun on the other hand
pleasure uh elation excitement all of
those other wonderful emotions as well
they're very positive emotions they're
dopamine driven okay so when you when
you're
when your body when your survival
re you know the survival of the species
for example depends on reproduction
uh procreation so sex feels very good
right and because it feels very good and
you know you've been trying to get that
girl to be you know with you for a while
and then suddenly she's you know
interested in you and oh my god the
dopamine hit that you get it's like
that's amazing that's the best feeling
i've ever felt and dopamine is an
excitatory what it's doing is it's
telling you do more do more do more and
in our nature of fun and pleasure and so
on we keep chasing it
so you know you have a tough week at
work you go to a party you jump up and
down music a couple of drinks and you're
just constantly hitting yourself with
rewards rewards rewards this feels good
this feels good
and two things happen one is your brain
receptors down regulate for the dopamine
they say okay okay hold on the baseline
is a lot of dopamine so i'm going to
keep that baseline and i'm going to look
for more so that's why you see people go
from
a party to a wilder party go from
running on the treadmill to jumping out
of an airplane right you're trying to
have more dopamine so you feel it that's
number one number two is dopamine gets
depleted so quickly
that when you run out of it
you want more and more like a drug
addict you literally get addicted to
dopamine and i always said that one of
the biggest reasons why people suffered
so much in in lockdown is because we
deprived them of their dopamine supply
okay we told people hold on hold on you
can't drown your unhappiness in parties
and fun and distractions you're gonna
have to sit with the
yourself for a while listen you're to
your brain saying something is wrong
okay and that completely gets you not
like a drug
addict really it gets you that
deprivation gives you withdrawal
symptoms
and and so when you compare the two of
them fun and playing video games with
your friends that's in the dopamine camp
for for a hundred percent and and the
thing is i said one is a calmer and the
other is an excitatory yeah so the
minute you get an injection of dopamine
in your blood serotonin is out so the
more you're dependent on dopamine the
more deprived of serotonin you are
and the harder it becomes to be happy
yeah
this is
like a kind of intellectually i've i've
i have known this for a while this idea
of serotonin is sort of inhibitory and
calming to physics excitatory but like
the way you're putting it now is i feel
like lots of pieces are slotting into
into place in my mind um one of the
things that i've been you know this is a
fairly fairly minor example but that
i've been thinking about these days is
do i want to get back into video games
oh you absolutely do yeah
i'm a serious video gamer
because like i used to be big on like
world of warcraft back in the day every
sort of
three and a half hours a day on average
for about you know 185 days of play time
when i was younger oh wow and those were
if i if i think back
those were i think some of the happiest
times that i remember whereas like
you've got this feeling you're working
with your friends you're taking down
this raid boss etc etc um but then kind
of when i got to university and started
replacing that with social interaction
you know at some point in fifth year of
med school i decided i was going to go
back into world of warcraft and because
my friends were telling me i'll let you
work too hard you need to like relax i
was like okay cool i'm gonna relax i'm
gonna go back into the video gaming
thing and i'd play a few hours and at
the end of it i would feel like really
drained yeah and it was not at all a
feeling of like being re-energized and
it's it's it was not the feeling of
relaxing it was a feeling of like oh my
god like
i've got all this stuff to do and i'm
thinking about it now i'm gonna be
theorycrafting like tomorrow morning
when i'm in a lecture and i'm supposed
to be doing medicine i'm actually going
to be reading up on what the optimal
warlock rotation is like all of this
stuff started happening in my brain and
then i kind of stopped a bit more and
then i feel like life became a bit more
calm um so i'm kind of thinking
so so that's an amazing example as a
matter of fact so the question is is
there anything wrong with fun okay not
always there is sometimes something
wrong with fun and sometimes not
so if if fun
is your escape
from a state of i'm
my mind is not calm
i have all of those things spending but
i'm just gonna play for a while yeah
you're using fun as a painkiller
it's like i have a headache and the
answer to the headache is i'll pop a
couple of pills right and then the
minute your the effect of the painkiller
goes away literally like exactly like
you described it the minute you're done
playing you're still drained you're
still you know and your brain
immediately goes like i have to do this
i have to do that are you numbing me
yeah and numbing me is what really fun
does in that space but if you're already
peaceful and calm and you found that
state of contentment
and then you add fun to it it's like a
supplement it's like taking a vitamin
it's like my life is already stable it's
already okay i'm on a good foundation
and i'm just gonna have a good time on
top of that right and it's wonderful my
so i am a very serious video gamer the
only thing i warn you against with video
games is if you go back i'll be the one
that kills you right so just
don't blame me for it but that's the how
the way it's uh it's played amazing yeah
just a little quick interlude on the
topic of happiness this is a very good
book the happiness advantage by sean
acker sean is this harvard professor who
does a bunch of research into the
psychology of happiness and his main
argument in the book is actually that
weirdly um being happy leads to success
rather than success leading to happiness
anyway you can read the book it's a very
good book i have a video about it on the
main channel but also what you can do is
you can read the book summary of the
book over at short form who are very
kindly sponsoring this episode short
form is by far and away the single best
service i have ever found for
summarizing books it's way more than
book summaries they don't just give you
a one page summary of the book they do
that but they also give you a chapter by
chapter summary of everything that's
going on in the book and in addition to
that they also include little segments
where if the author of a book has made a
claim and that claim has been disagreed
with by the author of another book they
will have a little kind of short form
note which draws in research from the
other author and says hey this is a
controversial point you should look into
this book by this author that says the
exact opposite thing and so really it's
a great way of actually kind of engaging
with the ideas in the book in a way more
efficient fashion and in a way more
integrated and engaging fashion than it
is actually just reading a simple book
summary i've been using short form for
the last several years anytime i get a
book recommendation i'll often look it
up on short form and if it's there then
i'll read that first and then that'll
help me decide if i actually want to
read the book it's also really helpful
when i'm actually making book videos
about these books because we will then
use the short form summary to be like oh
just revisiting the key ideas in the
book anyway if you want to check it out
then head over to short form dot com
forward slash deep dive and that url
will give you 20 off the annual premium
subscription but yeah short form is sick
and i'm super excited that they're a
sponsor of this episode
thank you for uh picking me up on the on
the video games thing because i so the
way i think of it or i thought of it
previously in my mind was
you know
my my mum occasionally asks me if i'm
happy
you know and then i'm like yeah i feel
like life is a 10 out of 10. and she's
like but you don't look very happy i'm
like i'm just you know i have a resting
board face i always seem to look too
tired bags under the eyes and all that
stuff but the way i was previously
defining it was that kind of contentment
was this sort of baseline level of peace
and acceptance and calm but then
happiness was a i i was always unsure is
happiness more like a kind of hour by
hour minute by minute fluctuation or or
when we say happiness are we referring
more to this sort of climate rather than
whether this idea of like long-term
long-term ish contentment i'm happy with
how life is going the the target is
definitely to be happy so so happiness
is binary okay so if you don't mind me
talk about let me talk about the
happiness equation for a minute so when
i when i struggled with my unhappiness
as a young man
having been given everything i was so
fortunate i had the most beautiful wife
two amazing kids you know
fortune and
power if you want i had so much money
the big villa and so on i was miserable
right and and the idea for me was like
so what is happening why is that why is
it not working for me
and i attempted in a very crazy
scientific way believe it or not as an
engineer i said okay so we're going to
have to look for that happiness thing
and what do engineers do the first thing
we do is we define the problem okay so
what is that happiness thing you need to
know what it is before you look for it
and interestingly there was no
definition anywhere and so i went out
and i said okay
let's write down moments
where we felt that thing called happy
and i wrote down i remember correctly 92
bullet points at the time i feel happy
when my daughter smiles i feel happy
when i have a good cup of coffee i feel
happy and i have an enriching
conversation and so on and i started to
look for
uh common commonalities between those
points
in an engineer's way i was literally
looking for a fitting line
okay it's like you know you take a few
random readings from a machine
and you just put them on a graph and if
there is a line that line is the
equation of how that machine performs i
was looking for that line i plotted
those moments against everything you
know my height my weight my you know age
my
hair on my head whatever that is right
and seriously i i was very open to the
idea of
those moments when i felt happy
were they because i lost my hair in my
late 20s that i started to feel unhappy
so it's a it's a worthwhile experiment
but no there was no relationship at all
the only relationship was this
happiness was not triggered by any
single event as a matter of fact the
same event
i said i feel happy when my daughter
smiles
that same event made me happy most of my
life
it made me very unhappy when she once
failed a class in school and came back
to from from school smiling
right when you know why is that when you
know i'm i generally i feel happy when
my daughter smiles but when she was
smiling after failing a class i sort of
had a feeling in my head that she maybe
not does not realize the weight of the
issue or that she's not responsible or
whatever but even the same event does
not always trigger happiness and when
you start to to see that you say so what
is happiness then it's not just the
events of our life there is something
else in the equation at play and the
other thing is your expectation
i expect that my daughter will smile all
the time other than the times where she
needs to be more responsible okay so my
expectation is when someone fails an
exam
they should not be very happy
okay interesting now you put that in an
equation and suddenly it becomes very
clear happiness is events minus
expectations right if you want to
complicate the equation a little bit
it's
great equal to or greater than
because if events beat expectations so
it's equal to or greater than the
perception of events
minus your your expectations of how life
should be
okay and and the joke i always tell and
maybe people have heard that before is
rain never makes you happy or unhappy
right brain makes you happy when uh it's
your ex-boyfriend's uh uh wedding yeah
right it makes you very unhappy when
it's your wedding yeah it's the same
rain right but you don't want it in your
wedding that's your expectation is that
life is gonna bless your wedding and
it's gonna pour on his
okay and and so when you realize that
you suddenly see
that
uh happiness is a lot more manageable
and when we talk about that then you
have the interesting definitions i gave
you events minus expectations means i'm
okay with life
events less than expectations which is
events missing expectations gives you a
very interesting definition of
unhappiness which i think
probably in my mind was the turning
point for me which was not the
definition of happiness was the
definition of unhappiness for two
reasons one is remember i told you we
are born happy our child like nature is
happy it's unhappiness that that is the
uh you know the the
anomaly to the norm
and you know you can see that very
clearly with children if a nappy gets
wet
the child
becomes unhappy there is a reason to cry
you remove that
uh you know that you change the the
diaper or the nappy and the child is
back to happiness right
more importantly
because when you realize that you
realize that
the child is actually unhappy because if
that wet diaper stays for a long time
it's going to cause you know skin
irritation and so we're as a machine we
humans are actually detecting a survival
threat every negative emotion you've
ever felt was detecting a survival
threat
when when my daughter comes back
uh smiling after you know
failing an exam
my survival threat is she's not taking
this seriously enough to study for the
exam next time it's a survivor threat
you know if if your partner says
something hurtful your survival threat
is are they gonna leave me do they not
like me anymore yeah and you can apply
that to every negative emotion a
politician
like you know our our news media will
tell you almost every day four times a
day that there is a corrupt politician
they'll find one okay and make that the
center of your life
and your survivor threat is how can i
feel safe when our politicians are
corrupt and keep going through that as
many times as you want
and you realize that this definition of
unhappiness being a survival mechanism
is the answer to everything
because what do you do about
threat alerts you know what what what do
you do if the fire alarm goes on
you react yeah you do something about it
you you you verify if that threat is
true yeah and if it is you take action
yeah that's not what we do with
unhappiness
interestingly
what we do with unhappiness is every 90
seconds yeah
instead of regenerating we regenerate
the emotion and we add drama to the
emotions i call it pain on the mat ah i
like that okay yeah netflix of
unhappiness it's like okay you know
remember that you know when when my uh
when the bully told me something in
school 14 years ago
let me play that again and tell myself
i'm not worth it and i'm not big enough
and i'm not good enough and i'm not and
i can tell that story for 27 years to go
if i want
interestingly
there is no more bully and most of us
don't keep that context most of us think
a threat in the past is worth thinking
about for the rest of our life
misleading
because the answer should be if there is
a threat today let me look at it today
and see if it's still there yeah and if
it is can i do something about it
absolutely okay so happiness equation
happiness is greater than or equal to
events minus expectations
um
so
one
one i guess issue with this idea issue
inverted commas that i've never quite
been able to square is
the response of
does that therefore mean that we should
just have low expectations for
everything in life and you know always
think of life with a slightly
pessimistic outlook so that whatever
happens then life's it's a surprise and
it's a good thing
and when people say that to me i kind of
think yes yeah yes asterisks well i
don't know what the asterisk is if if
you if your if your target in life is to
be happy yeah okay honestly then yeah
lower expectations will make you happier
okay so you know if you know if you if
you basically tell yourself i know i
know many friends in my life that
decided that they've had enough of life
uh you know the fast-paced lives they
went and lived in the dominican republic
and the only thing that would make them
unhappy on a day is that there is not
enough wind to kite surf
okay and they make enough money to live
a very simple life and they want to kite
surf that's it their expectations are
very low
they don't expect a ferrari they don't
expect to be able to live in a big city
they don't want to go to museums
expectations are low and apply that to
anything now you go to india and if you
know many many people hundreds of
millions of people don't expect to eat
today give them a bowl of rice and
they're very happy
so if your target is happiness yeah
that's the way to go
okay if your target is success and
impact on life however you need to go to
the art you go you need to go the
opposite way okay and the opposite way
is i need ambition so so you know when i
wrote solve for happy at the beginning i
wrote it with the mission of 10 million
happy yeah and then 10 million happy
happened very quickly and my team
got together and said maybe we should
set a bigger target so we didn't set
eleven we didn't set a hundred million
is that a billion happy now a billion
happy is a crazy target to have how many
people in the world have reached a
billion people right
but it's a nice ambitious
uh a target to aspire to so when i wake
up in the morning uh year one
when we've you know we've achieved
another 10 million or so
i don't tell myself that's it we've
achieved we're done yeah i say to myself
there is still way to go there is still
more to do okay but now so you're stuck
between those two extents if you want
one that says have no expectation at all
and you'll be happy yeah and the other
is says have extremely high expectations
and you'll be successful what's the
problem with the modern world is that we
believed in this and not that
but you know the problem with the modern
world is when you're growing up i i'm
sure i don't know your mom but your mom
told you success is more important than
happiness go thrive in life success
leads to happiness or that success leads
to happiness right so we believe that
yeah well it's not true i mean how often
do you meet someone who's successful and
rich and famous and swimming in money
and everyone's attracted to them and
paparazzis are all around them and
they're miserable okay success doesn't
always lead to happiness now
between those two there is a midpoint
like everything in life which is
i need a realistic expectation a
realistic expectation is not lowered
than how it should be yeah and it's not
higher than how it should be i need an
ambitious
ambition that is higher than the
realistic expectation and i need a
contentment that sometimes my even my
realistic expectation might be missed
okay and in that case
while i aim for a realistic expectation
and a high ambition yep i'm getting the
best of both worlds yes i'm trying to be
successful and at the same time i'm
contented as i go through that path when
life misses my expectations sometimes oh
sick okay this is nice so i have this
dilemma when it comes to the book that
i'm working on um which is
the dilemma of
uh what is what should what should be my
ambition for the book
when it comes to writing one of the
classic accolades is hitting the new
york times bestseller list and so i have
this as a very clear thing like okay if
i was being quite ambitious about this i
would be like hey i want the book to be
a new york times bestseller
but there's something about that that
like when i sit down to write it
in a way it doesn't it doesn't feel good
it doesn't feel if it feels like almost
demotivating because that's a thing
that's outside of my control
whereas when i think of it as
the objective of this book is i want to
write a book i'm proud of and i want to
enjoy the journey along the way hmm
that's a very kind of contentment type
goal rather than an ambitious type goal
i think and when i lean towards that
then i feel oh it's all good i i feel
the parasympathetic
kind of activation rather than the
sympathetic activation which is what i
feel for the more ambitious goal
now i think this is great because then i
can optimize for happiness and just
write the book that i want but then part
of me wonders that like
is am i missing something but not going
for a more ambitious goal by not putting
a number on saying i want to get a
million sales i want to get three
million sales because sales translates
to impact on the one hand but also more
money and all of the other selfish
desires on the other hand
any any thoughts about that particular
lots of thoughts okay so i want to cover
this in if you'll allow me in two layers
fantastic so layer one
is a a very very important definition
okay
you know we're video gamers so i always
say life is like a video game and we can
come back to that conversation in a
minute
but if life
is a game
there are two types of games that are
defined one is an infinite game and the
other is a finite game a finite game is
a game where there is a target a
destination and a win
okay an infinite game is like pac-man
have you ever checked your score when
you were playing pac-man you don't know
the purpose of pac-man was to play
pac-man for as long as you're playing
pac-man okay and then sometimes you you
know you lose and then you play again
you know there is there is no
very very few people who are trying to
be world champions on on pac-man and so
they were monitoring the score
life is an infinite game because the the
the finite bit of it is when you die and
you're no longer playing that's it so as
long as you're in this game
your target is what is to play
interestingly it's not to achieve
anything so the most interesting
part of life is
for most of us who are highly engaged in
the modern world
if you remove the target
suddenly everything becomes okay
everything becomes so enjoyable yeah i
write
honestly ali i write to write
i i write at least two and a half times
more books than what i publish
and i don't care
okay i wake up sometimes in the morning
and i write for
three four five hours and then i look at
that stuff and i say i have no use for
it i wrote it anyway
i loved the journey of writing it i
loved the journey of exploration i loved
the analysis the research i loved the
conversation i had with a friend to say
does this make sense to you i love all
of that and it's you know what it's it's
hours of my life that are filled with
joy
if i told myself on the other hand hey
look we need to get a book out in six
weeks don't waste your hours on doing
that stuff write the stuff that you need
to put in the book
it will be a crappy book
honestly because the target is not to
explore and research and enjoy the
target is i need to put ink on paper you
might as well copy something from the
internet and put it on paper right and
you know with your reputation or my
reputations will probably sell anyway
right now
so so the idea of an infinite game
that
is when life is joyful
where i wake up in the morning and i say
and i truly say that to myself what are
we going to play today
today there is going to be a little bit
of joy in
solving a challenge there is a little
bit of joy in being with a loved one
there is a little bit of joy in
cooking a meal or whatever
and and that infinite game is not
restricted by time
because for as long as you're playing
the game is going on yep interesting
the other side of this is
uh when you think
of
having
targets
that are so blinding for us i i do a
very simple exercise i ask myself why
okay why why do i want to be a
bestseller
right
and the first thing that you will get
normally is an answer that says because
it will impact more people
yeah
yeah your brain is sort of telling you
that you're god and you have the ability
to make a difference to a lot of people
which by the way honestly is the
byproduct of of doing a great job on the
on the infinite game
but then underneath that
and i say those with respect you know i
told you i'm a big fan right
we and and i'm like you every one like
of us there are other negative secondary
targets
you know three million copies multiplied
by the royalties a lot of money or
you know and and i've seen some of your
personal finance videos and you're
encouraging people all the time to make
money to save money to do all of that
because it's the right thing to do so
interesting i'm i'm sort of thinking in
your head that when you've done that
you're going to add book to your revenue
streams and you're going to be able to
teach people that book uh is a good idea
for revenues to sell a course about how
to write a book
this is a secondary this is a secondary
a secondary objective okay
so it sounds like you're saying with
when it comes to quote ambitious goals
let's question the goal to figure out
where it comes from
and whether we actually care about like
genuinely care about the things that
lately ambitious goal yeah and also by
the way if if the achieving the goal is
going to deliver what we think it's
going to be
oh yeah so so if you tell yourself
because if i make the financial sorry
the new york times bestseller list i'll
be well known yep you're forgetting that
you already have three million followers
you're already well known yeah right and
and the reality is that books you know
rarely ever sell three million copies uh
you know i think there has been less
than a you know maybe a thousand five
hundred books if my numbers are correct
that has ever sold more than a million
copy so including the bible and harry
potter so you have very serious
competition there right and and then and
then think about
is that the only path is there another
path that's easier okay is there another
way that i can enjoy the book and maybe
achieve only a hundred thousand readers
whatever that is
yeah yeah so kind of my my target for
the book at the moment like after after
doing some soul searching about this new
york times thing was that like uh it
would be nice if it happens but like i
am going to try my best to not even
think about that yeah unless i'm having
a conversation like this where it's a
nice sort of like dichotomy example
and the you know the thing that i i
think about is yeah i want a book that
i'm happy with i want a book that i
enjoy writing um and i want a book that
uh can have
some some kind of impact on some kind of
people yeah and i i find this with the
youtube channel as well and this podcast
that the less i look at the numbers the
more calm and content i feel that's true
so you have a very ambitious goal one
one billion people happy it's a
different goal so what so what's going
on there it's a different goal so so i i
think the biggest the biggest mistake
with capitalism is how we define success
capitalism as a system
is a very efficient system it works
rewards drive effort
execution drives success
it's beautiful okay and there is fair
competition or unfair sometimes but at
least there is a competitive landscape
where you can where you really want to
excel to do something
this the problem with capitalism is not
the system the problem with capitalism
is the target and the target is dollar
signs yeah now if if your target is a
billion happy people
that's the best form of billionaire you
will ever need to be yep okay and and
i don't i don't know how to say this any
other way i mean
because people don't believe me when i
say this i made so much money
most of the time by the way the money i
made came from places i didn't expect
it's number one
my daughter sometimes tells me you've
been paid in advance
because you were not worthy of the money
that you made you need to make give the
world back now okay
i give most of my money away and i wear
four dollar t-shirts okay and i promise
you they're easier
to handle and deal with and travel with
than the 40 or 400 dollar t-shirts that
my
friends will wear okay
and i literally i have
very little of my money left
but that little that is left is actually
enough
and tomorrow there will be more money
hopefully if there isn't there will be
four less four dollar t-shirts it's
really not that complicated when you
think about it
and that peace of mind
of i'm not chasing this illusion anymore
yep
that peace of mind that clarity of i've
had everything yep from rolls royces to
bentleys to ferraris too
and you know what the challenge is ali
you sit i promise you i had 16 cars in
my garage and i it was a very vivid
eye-opening moment for me because i
arrived from a a trip took one of the
cars out and i had to pee somewhere at
10 pm so it was dark i was driving and
for that one second i actually couldn't
remember which car i'm driving
right because in reality when you're
driving what are you looking at you're
looking at the road
and all cars are the same when you're
looking at the road okay especially by
the way in the modern era of cars where
quality is so high that all cars are
more or less the same right and so
when you realize that you say so why do
i have two i mean if they're all the
same why do i have two not let alone 16.
and you can take that same target that
same illusion if you want and apply it
to everything
you apply it to
how many uh um you know houses can a
rich man have
many
you know some some people have
you know in the hundreds of properties
and houses how many beds can you sleep
on
one
okay how many meals can you eat
one and is our palate really really
refined enough to know that tiny bit of
champagne that was added at the very lot
yeah honestly honestly if you tell
yourself that you're lying to yourself
or maybe i'm a different human being
maybe i don't have a tongue okay but
food to me if you go to an indian
restaurant that basically serves you
something for a couple of pounds
sometimes or five pounds sometimes it's
delicious as delicious as when you go to
that amazing restaurant
that costs you 500 pounds
the only difference between them is ego
the only difference between them is
i don't go to the five pound place i go
to the five pound place all the time and
i meet the nicest people in the five
pound place and i and i have the most
amazing experiences and yeah sometimes i
go to the more expensive places as well
but but i own my life my life doesn't
own me there's such an a big difference
between i can't have this
or i can have whatever i want whatever i
feel like
and i'm not confined to wearing an
armani suit and eating in a
i don't know
let's not name any restaurants because
most of their owners are my friends so
right but but that but that's the truth
the truth is you remove your ego you
remove your conditioning yep and life
becomes a lot more delicious
and and and i will tell you i still make
money
a lot it's my skill i've spent 30 years
being a businessman
the biggest joy you will ever get out of
that money is twofold
one
is making it
so you own it but it doesn't own you
yep so my last startup mega failure lost
a lot of money lost two and a half years
of my life because my partner did a
mistake that he wasn't supposed to do
right
didn't even blink
like so what
i lost a lot of money but i also like
like the concept of i lost ali but i had
ali
i lost a lot of money but i made a lot
of money that i didn't think i deserved
right
at the same time what you do with that
money and i'm not i'm not claiming to be
like a mega charitable person but the
biggest joy you'll ever get out of the
money is to help someone out
and and honestly
you know
the people that have money that are
within my friends zone that are really
happy
answer only one question when i tell
them i answer only one answer when i ask
them with a question i say why are you
making money and they say because it
enables me to do good things
okay so the happiest rich people are the
ones and there are not many of them but
i know a few
that that will tell you because if i
manage to make a million dollars more
then i can invest in that project and
that project is going to make a
difference and by the way while it's
making a difference it's also making
money
which is another million dollars i can
put in that other project that i wish
would why i would do to change the world
those who have
targets that are
um uh focused on themselves are driven
by ego yeah and they're always going to
be disappointed those who have targets
that are focused on others are driven by
by compassion
and they will always have the joy of
feeling that they made a difference to
another person
i i say you are born a millionaire
okay each and every one of us is born
with somewhere around 500 000 hours of
life
of active life okay
each one of those hours
if you multiply them by 60 minutes each
one of those minutes
you have now 30 million minutes right
you're a millionaire already every
minute that you that you use
you're exchanging that minute for
something else
yeah so your asset your only asset is 30
million minutes
if i were to spend
2 000 of those minutes with you to
create this podcast
what return to my well-being to my life
to my feelings uh to my happiness to my
connection to the world to my value set
that those two 2000 minutes are worse
right if i use them swiping on instagram
if i use them to make a hundred pounds
more
and the question is a hundred pounds is
worth it it's a good thing
but if it's exchanged for 2000 minutes
and i can do something else with the
2000 minutes maybe it's not yeah and and
the point is within context when do you
stop and say no more of my minutes are
needed
to create more and more and more
ambition yeah okay oh nice right so
that's number one number two is the
stoics have always taught you and most
most religious and spiritual teachings
have always taught you to simulate
suffering yeah okay if you simulate
suffering suddenly you realize
what it is that you actually have so
that you instead of looking for what you
don't and continuing to be ambitious you
start to look at what you have and go
like this is amazing so you know i i i
am
multi-faith spiritual if you want to if
you want to describe how i look at life
and i practice a lot of things you know
meditation from certain really you know
spiritual practices i fast in ramadan in
islam and so on and so forth
and i will tell you ramadan was just a
month ago
an incredible experience
because you're supposed to not eat and
drink and you know have sex between
sunrise and sunset
and
and you know the first day you go like
wow there are people that live like that
you know who are somewhere in a desert
or who don't have enough to eat there
are people that feel like that
by day 20 ali
you're like i'm the most blessed person
on the planet there are people that live
that way 20 days in a row and i promise
you by day 20 you're like this is i'm so
blessed to even have a a glass of water
at any point and and then the next time
i sip a cup of tea
i'm like man that tea really tastes good
yeah and and by simulating suffering
whether in your head or in practice
to say i am so blessed
suddenly you get to the point where you
say okay so
i may now want to reconsider how i'm
going to place my minutes going forward
this is enough
how do i place the next minute
my in my
silly analysis i'll say that there are
only two
rewarding minutes that you can spend one
is a minute of connection to a human
to an animal to the environment to a
connection a minute of collection okay
and the other is a minute of giving
and you know again i'm not saying this
because i'm that you know
lovely spiritual guru it is very selfish
giving is an incredible joy it truly is
it truly and there is a ton of research
that you know where they give 20 to
people and ask some of them to give it
to friends and others not
your happiness goes through the roof not
just through the act of giving it seems
somehow
that the physics of the universe
favors those who give
so it's not just that my moment of
giving someone something or spending a
minute teaching someone something i knew
feels good
i will tell you my life is so easy
because it seems that life is pushing me
forward it's not you know it's not
really
opposing me because i'm trying to grab
at it
it's saying good go good boy you know
you're helping others i want to help
others too so i'm going to help you a
little here is a little bit of a push on
your you know on your little bum and
move forward
i would love to get your take on this it
seems like a lot of people achieve a
bunch of success first and then realize
oh i'm going to become a bit of a monk
and become a bit of a spiritual like oh
it's all about the journey you know
literally we've released notebooks that
say
quote from brandon sanderson journey
before destination and i sometimes think
that like
is this
sort of this whole thing about you know
sulfur happy and stuff
the domain of the privileged where
you've already solved for safety and
food and shelter and now you've got the
luxury of solving for happy yeah and
then i often wonder like when i'm giving
advice and videos am i talking to the
audience that's already solved the basic
thingies
or
and and i know there will be people in
my audience like sometimes we get
comments i i made a video called eight
habits that made me a millionaire it's
like whatever and one of the comments
was bro i live in like some village in
yemen i have i i struggle to get food
and water like easy for you to say all
of this
and i think
that's a that's a very good point like i
i have no response to that um what do
you what do you what do you reckon
yeah solving for happy is uh the
the did you call it the domain of the
privilege
yeah we're all privileged
if you're you know maybe the the the
gentleman in yemen is not
but
between what you're talking about and
where that gentleman in yemen is
uh
there are
70
700 million people yep that are unhappy
while privileged right okay that's
number one number two if that gentleman
in yemen had a device an electronic
device connected to the internet so that
he can write that and he had an hour of
safety to watch your video or ten
minutes of safety to watch your video
then there are seven
million others in yemen that are less
privileged than him
okay and and yes of course life for each
of us has challenges but interestingly
life for each of us has lots of
blessings
and gratitude the ability to actually
look at life and say
yes
i am not going to be a millionaire like
ali
but i am at least not captive
as a sex-trafficked woman like
three million women in the world
that ability to look at that
actually is what victor franklin frankel
teaches as iron man search for reason
is that there is always someone
that is less privileged than you and we
go back to that topic of relativity
that you know i broke up with my uh my
boyfriend someone would say i'm
brokenhearted yes but you're still
privileged compared to the one that
didn't yeah and her boyfriend's abusing
her for example okay who is also
privileged over the one that is being
captive and and so on
so part of my work in seoul for happy
was a concept that i call look down
sadly we always look up we say you know
i you know i have a
mercedes and he has a ferrari or i
am in the bus and he's in his mercedes
or i'm walking and he's in the bus or
i'm not able to walk and he's walking
and you can always go down
of course of course life is tough so
this is the interesting thing so one of
the philosophies of a lot of spiritual
teachings
is that your test
is always a tiny lit and tiny little bit
more stretching than your capabilities
so it's not it's not you never really
get tested in life as per your
capabilities because that wouldn't be a
test and you never really get an easy
test
you always get a test that is a tiny bit
if it's too challenging you're gonna
break life doesn't want that so why does
life
challenge us for two reasons
reason number one
is to
learn something and most of us as we
look back at our life and the difficult
parts of our life whatever they were
if you were born in yemen not in
you know in in the uk
then yes there is an interesting
challenge between privilege
between living in yemen and living in
the uk but that privilege
sorry that lack of privilege that's
challenge that you're facing is suited
for what you need to learn
and then you know
if
if you so i always say if i if i when
ali left our world when my son left our
world
i had so much money
i had no idea how much money i had okay
i'm i promise you money was would pour
in from everywhere
and i lost my son
if i had lost all of my money i promised
you ali if i had lost all of my money
down to zero
i wouldn't have blinked
would not have blinked the only way for
love to for life to stop me
and say it's time to change direction
it's time to stop focusing on being a
chief business officer of google x it's
time to stop traveling the world like a
maniac trying to sell more technology
it's time to do what you were supposed
to do and write about happiness and
teach people about happiness the only
way that would take my notice
was for ali to leave
if it was anything else i promise you i
would have gone more into business and
it's so interesting so life either wants
you to learn or wants you to change
direction
and every time you either learn or
change direction you move on and then
there is another test it wants you to
learn or change direction okay every
time you do that so you you
date bad boys
right the bad boy treats you bad so you
get heartbroken and cry
you all right
that's the test you go out and date
another bad boy you're still in the same
place and a third bad boy you're still
in the same place until
suddenly
you go like that's it i learned change
direction
i'm not gonna date bad boys anymore
you date a good man
or a good woman or whatever your
preference is and then suddenly you have
a new challenge
and the cute new challenge is how can we
align around having a family yeah right
and that doesn't work you're heartbroken
then you see another one still good good
but not ready
you're still the same and then right and
then the third fourth whatever takes you
you get you get you grasp the test and
you say okay i'm gonna talk to them
about my family intentions before we
date
and when you start to do that you're
good yeah and then the next challenge so
it's almost like little you know math
exams
you need to understand addition and when
you do we'll teach you multiplication
okay
so individual challenges for individual
people one at a time
and your challenge is different than
mine yeah okay so you i don't know you
if that's true but you may actually find
it difficult to lose all your money i
know people who may find it more
difficult to lose their all of their
money than to lose their son
okay my test is for me
okay and for each and every one of us
that that test is just a tiny bit more
stretching so you can achieve it you can
succeed but it's made for you yeah
nice
speaking of tests a bit of a weird segue
yeah what what's going on in your dating
life these days what's that experience
bit
why why is everyone talking to me about
this i was with steven yesterday a
couple of days ago and spoke about the
same topic
what's going on in my dating life
lots so i i married my college
sweetheart amazing woman still my best
friend
enriched my life in every possible way
you spent 27 years together raised a
couple of kids together
and then we separated seven years ago
and i tried different models
uh and realized eventually which i think
actually is not does not only apply to
me
that interestingly life is a question of
context
um so so even your dating life is a
question of context that within context
you could want different things in life
and and for most of us we
have been sold that traditional
uh
way of relationships should look that
way
and in finding love my my my book about
the economics of love and romance
one of my favorite chapters which is
already written is all the different
models and if you look at life in the
last
10 15 20 years since you know dating
apps started and since we finally
finally finally accepted that everyone
is free to to to live the way they want
to live in their sexuality and gender
identity and so on
finally we started to realize that there
isn't one model yeah the one model of
i'm gonna live that life with one person
and there is a contract between us and
it's gonna be a lifetime yeah
there are endless models endless models
today i am in a place where i finally
realized around a year ago
that i have to say i appreciate my
mission and the importance of my mission
in my life more than i appreciate a
traditional relationship
right you appreciate your mission more
than
i'm much more committed and i'm much
more
interested in the success of my one
billion happy mission
than i am in having another traditional
relationship
okay
so so my life follows
very unusual seasons if you want and
those seasons are not the seasons of a
normal person at all
and i think that the one thing that
drove it home for me is i interviewed
matthieu ricard
and mature was um he's the he's probably
the world's most renowned uh monkey and
a good friend
and matthieu was a
cellular biology phd
very very very sophisticated uh person
and then by age 29 if i remember
correctly he left left the whole world
behind and became a monk
and he was well known for his dedication
i mean sometimes he would go into his
hermitage for years at the time alone in
isolation
and i asked him and i said mathieu why
why does a monk has to be celibate why
does a monk have to sit you know to
leave the world behind yeah
and he simply said well moe understand
if i had a woman in my life and children
and i dedicated that
uh you know and i had my responsibility
for them it would be so unfair for them
when i go following my teachers or when
i go in reflection or when i go right
would be so unfair to them so you had to
make a choice now i'm not a monk for
sure okay but my choice
does not allow me to stay in one place
where my relationship takes 30 percent
of my day and effort yeah okay so i'm in
flow really i have wonderful experiences
in my life with amazing amazing human
beings that enrich my life that are not
as attached to that traditional model
and when i say that i'm sure that some
of our listeners will judge me okay
but that's okay because it's me it's the
way i live yeah with full honesty to the
point that i can say it to your three
million people okay and i think that
honesty is highly appreciated with the
with the women that actually want to be
part of that honesty
and that's how i live nice i love that
um do you interesting okay yeah no
judgment yeah great that's great um
so i am about eight and a bit and a bit
months into my relationship and it's the
longest i've ever dated someone uh any
advice for
what it is that uh any or any tips for
long-term relationship quote success
slash happiness i don't know how to say
this politely so i'm going to say it in
a rude way that's okay
nudity
in a very interesting way
the only way that makes a relationship
work is that there is nothing ever
hidden okay okay nothing ever hidden
we wear masks all the time ali we wear
masks all the time i try i try as much
as i can not to but i still do right i
mean
when you talk about my writing people
ask me so what's so special about your i
write like an engineer i say
an engineer is a form of ego i'm not an
engineer i'm mo right i was an engineer
at a point in time i'm now probably more
of an author than an engineer right and
i don't know why i keep saying i'm an
engineer yeah i have a very structured
way of writing but it's a form of ego
yeah
when i'm with someone that i love
that engineer surfaces
that engineer shows up and starts to say
that's the way i do life but believe it
or not again life is context
when i'm in a romantic relationship of
any form
it's not about the engineer at all
yeah as a matter of fact it's a lot more
about
letting go of the engineer okay of about
following your heart and opening up and
discussing things and so on yeah so in
my personal view the the couples that
flow and get to where they need to go
are couples that ha that hide nothing at
all nothing at all nothing okay if sex
was amazing yesterday you should say
it's amazing okay if it wasn't you
should talk about it
if you like to go to fancy restaurants
you you know you should say it if she
likes to go to fancy restaurants she
should say it okay if you don't however
you shouldn't hide that you should say
baby i would go for you yeah it's not my
place
okay
and anything
now
one of the very very controversial
topics that i discuss
briefly in that little voice in your
head in one chapter but i discuss
deeply in her the book about the
feminine
and in finding love
is that we have differences
between
uh us
that are not dependent on our body parts
but they are dependent on our
you know um the way we live our life in
the feminine or in the masculine each
and every one of us has masculine and
feminine in them okay
but some of us tend to go through life
more in their masculine
man or woman straight or gay doesn't
matter you some of us would behave in
qualities that are more masculine
and some of us will behave in qualities
that are more feminine man or woman
straight or gay
what's the difference
if you're a linear thinker for example
you're living in your masculine could be
man or woman but you're a linear thinker
that's the way you analyze your problem
then you are in your masculine if you're
intuitive
then you're in your feminine in every
relationship
there is attraction
and tension
the attraction is what gives the comfort
and harmony and beautiful hugs
the tension is what creates playfulness
silliness
and sexuality
if if you don't have a little bit of
both the relationship is not complete
and the challenge is the tension happens
because of those differences
because you're a linear thinker
and she's intuitive or the other way
around so those differences believe it
or not between between the two partners
are like chinese
and czech
or a slovakian slovakian or whatever
that is right
there's totally different languages yeah
to the point that when
she behaves in a certain way or your
partner he or she doesn't matter
you completely don't get it
most of the of the questions i get on
the topic
would be like why is she like that like
what happened right the only way to find
out why she's like that is two steps
step one is for you to listen
and step two is for her to talk
okay and for most of us
when we do those things it's almost in a
foreign language it's like she starts to
say abc and you go like why is she
saying four five six yeah right and the
only way to actually start to translate
is to pause and say
i didn't get it
i didn't get it
i didn't get it i mean one of one of the
of the examples of that is i had a
person in my life where we were dating
and then we broke up and then you know i
love her dearly she's a wonderful woman
and you know last time i was here in
london i couldn't give her enough time
and this and she she was very upset and
she said you know i want you to give me
more time and so this time around i
texted her i saw her several times
and then one of them i said uh i and
then i texted her and said am i doing
better than last time
okay
her answer was silence
total silence
in in a masculine brain this is my
engineer measuring performance yeah okay
in her feminine side she was like is
this a task on him does he feel that
this is a burden on him okay so i waited
because that's what communication is all
about communication is not just about
talking all the time
communication is about also silence
sometimes there were some times to think
about it to give me some time to read it
again i waited
and then
when she answered back and said i felt
from your answer now look at what she's
done what she's done here she allowed
herself to talk
i felt from your answer that you feel
that it's a burden to spend time with me
okay
what did i do i waited
yeah because if i responded immediately
it would be an argument
and then a couple of hours later i
responded and i said but it could also
be understood that i care so much for
you to be happy yeah
and i was asking if i'm doing the right
thing just in case i wasn't to be able
to
do better
communication that's great done yeah
right and by the way this
is so enriching
because the minute you get it
you suddenly look at her and she looks
at you and you go like oh my god she's
so wonderful
she felt that way this is why it was
silence it's not a fight
she felt that way it was silence it's
either because i did something shitty
yeah or she misunderstood what i what i
did okay which basically means i need to
correct what i did or maybe i need to
explain what i did and most of the time
challenges between couples are
you know honestly when there is a
challenge between a couple i i basically
always say
that's because you care about each other
if you didn't you would have walked away
yeah right and i think a lot of that
really comes to that feminine and
masculine
a lot of that comes to the fact that you
really are talking chinese yep
and she's talking slovekian or whatever
that is
yeah i recently reread meta from mars
women are from venus yeah which is great
yeah a great great illustration of that
it's quite it's quite controversial
these days um but
i mean honestly
it really helped me
understand lots of things it's not if
you don't look at men and women
okay so so let me talk about this
concept for a bit yeah
qualities are a beautiful thing so so
let me explain you you have on we said
linear thinking and intuition yeah right
masculine and feminine
you have um
for example uh forcefulness and
playfulness yeah so men you know the
masculine is strong the feminine is
playful is in flow right you have um
empathy and compassion so sorry or
compassion and empathy empathy is
feminine is to feel what another person
is feeling
compassion is to act upon what you're
feeling oh okay okay and so on i can
give you a million examples
now take any of them i want some let's
let's list some of my favorites which
are really under under rated in the
world
um
the feminine
is um
as i said is intuitive it's also
creative all of creativity comes from
the feminine it's also in flow so it
doesn't resist life it's also um
you know into oneness and inclusion so
the masculine has that idea of it's an
individual against the world the
feminine is
i'm part of the world i'm part of all
being
okay they're a quality they're an
approach an attitude to deal with life
okay if i'm given a problem the
masculine will take that problem and say
let me analyze it in linear format
the feminine will say let me sense it
and understand all of the different
inputs and then trust my intuition
is one better than the other
depends on the problem
absolutely not every problem requires
both
every single problem requires both okay
and if you if you drop one
and stick to the other you're limited
so so linear thinking yeah when you
haven't sensed properly all of the
different inputs is stupid because
you're analyzing not enough information
yeah okay
getting all of the input from sensing or
from your intuition or you know
and not analyzing it is very ineffective
the game is can we
integrate yeah can we put those two
together the the modern world however
has demonized the feminine
why because we're capitalists
the masculine is all about doing the
feminine is all about being
beautiful
we don't get being in that fast-paced
modern world being by the way is
not me creating a video
but me being who i am
so that when i create a video people go
like this guy is good this guy actually
has a mission and he believes in
something yeah that being might be more
effective than the words i put in my
video yeah you understand and and
actually this is felt i'm i told you i'm
a fan
of your work for some reason when i look
at your videos i go like i like this
person
it's not what you're saying i just like
you as a person
that's part of your being not what
you're doing interesting
so where does it go wrong the the modern
world wants more doing because we just
want more profits and more success and
more numbers
and is demonizing the feminine
when in reality every single person that
ever made the world a better place this
might
sound shocking
was more in their feminine
in their masculine gandhi
could have rallied
one billion people to fight the brits
right instead he went into
non-violent resistance
non-violence that's 100 feminine
gandhi in that choice was more feminine
than masculine
okay
the most shocking example that i write
about in her is steve jobs
so most people will think that steve
jobs succeeded because he was hyper
masculine obnoxious pushy forceful and
so on aggressive sometimes which are the
extremes of the masculine no this is
what pulled him back this is why he was
taken off as a ceo at the beginning what
made steve jobs steve jobs is his
empathy for the user needs his
understanding of color and beauty his
understanding of art and calligraphy
yeah and and and you know and his his
his appreciation of simplicity his
appreciation of play and flow and so on
and so forth these are what made him
successful
the feminine is what makes made him
successful interestingly the masculine
is very good at doing even if what we're
doing is a stupid thing
okay this is why we create amazing
technologies that are destroying our
planet if we allowed a little more
feminine the feminine would come in and
say is there any way we can create some
way to go to australia and not destroy
the planet at the same time because we
care about going to australia and not
destroying the planet
so finally what i try to say is
where does it go wrong it goes wrong if
you overdo any of those qualities so if
if you take strong
strong is a masculine uh trait yeah if
you take strong
and uh and uh use it properly it leads
to protection and safety of our tribe
you do too much of it it becomes
aggression and violence right you take
intuition
intuition allows us to see what was not
what is not obvious and trust and
connect to the rest of intelligence if
you want okay do a little bit of that
you get a better knowledge of life do
too much of it
and you're not practical in your
analytic analysis of the problem yep
right and so on yeah so so where is the
where is the answer the answer is for a
couple
to literally come together and say hey
i'm crap at this
you're amazing at it you're you lead on
this one i'm good at this you're not so
good at it let me lead on that one
and then suddenly those two become so
much better than each one of them alone
nice
yeah this is sort of like again
having that experience of lots of
puzzles slotting into into space in my
brain um
two things come to mind actually one and
one in particular um
where
uh the i was having a chat with my
girlfriend let's call her jane uh that
uh around
it it was really around around intuition
and jane was asking you know do i ever
get the feeling of bad vibes from anyone
and i was like
not really like if they give me a reason
to suspect that their behavior that
their kind of intentions are misaligned
or like you know malicious intent and
all that but probably not most people
are good most of the time like it's all
good
and we were in um we were on we were on
holiday and um some guy came up to us
and was offering to buy us a bus ticket
to go somewhere i was like oh what a
nice guy he's offering to buy us a bus
ticket and she was like no
he's right it doesn't feel right let's
not do this thing and we're talking
about this afterwards where she felt
like maybe for me the fact that i don't
really feel the bad vibes was a bit of a
red flag because it's like oh i don't i
don't have the situation that this
person could be dangerous therefore
would that be bad for the family further
down the line
um my solution to this was
genuinely i don't i don't feel the bad
vibes i think everyone has good
intentions most of the time given that
you're better at this why don't we just
default to yours exactly if you ever get
a whiff of bad vibes from someone we
just don't do the thing and i would i
won't even question it absolutely and
she was like yeah that's reasonable
that's a reasonable resolution to the
problem absolutely that's the weight
exactly that's the way it goes it is for
you to realize
that her intuition is such a valuable
asset that you would so benefit from
having and rather than fight over it
yeah
appreciate it yeah okay
yeah this is all like yeah this is all
really resonating i think part of and i
like that distinction you you drew with
men from ours which is that the the only
reason is controversial is if you attach
to men and women it's not men and women
rather than masculine feminine
absolutely
even with the labels masculine and
feminine i think
it would be nice if we had a phrasing
for them that was not so
gendered in a way
because it immediately reflects people's
minds oh my god
yeah that's the exact problem the exact
problem for me is i am i am crazy about
the idea of everyone should be free yeah
to do exactly what they want to identify
exactly what they want so i'll give you
an example i uh for
my diet through my years has changed in
a very unusual way so there was a time
where i ate no chicken no meat
but i no eggs
but i drank milk
and i ate fish occasionally but no other
seafood
and so when i explained that to people
they would say okay so you're vegan
vegan vegan oh but you drink milk that
means you're vegetarian but you don't
eat eggs
maybe you're still a vegetarian who
doesn't like eggs but you eat fish
occasionally does that make you a
pescetarian right and and i was like i'm
a mortarian right i eat what i want what
i like do i have to fit within a
category do i do you have to call me
something
or can i just order and say no red meat
please yeah okay no chicken please
is that is that so difficult for
humanity to understand why do we try to
categorize everything okay and so as we
now expand it from finally from man
woman
into you can be any gender you want
i want to be a moterian
i want to be more identify as i as what
i identify and nobody should judge me
for that
right nobody should try to fit me within
a category yeah if i if i want to
identify as a as a a double-decker bus
okay there doesn't need to be a category
for that honestly i can identify with
whatever i want this is the true freedom
we're looking for this is the true
revolution if you if you ask me and i
know that the reason why we're going
through this phase is because it was so
extreme that we're teething through it
okay but my dream is to end up in a
place where
i don't need to identify at all i'm mo
i am i am the person that i am i live
the way i want to live as long as i
don't hurt anyone okay
you don't have to put me in a box i'm
saying that's a great place to end this
i can't wait to read the books and um
yeah okay
we'll we'll put links to all of the
stuff all of the books um that you've
really so far including that little
voice in your head which should be out
by the time this podcast is released so
links to all of that will be in the
video description and in the show notes
um yeah i just wanted to say thank you
so much for coming on this has been an
absolute joy i feel like so much stuff
in my head has like connected into
interesting different places such a
pleasure to have to to be here big fan
thank you for the opportunity thank you
so much for coming all right so that's
it for this week's episode of deep dive
thank you so much for watching or
listening all the links and resources
that we mentioned in the podcast are
going to be linked down in the video
description or in the show notes
depending on where you're watching or
listening to this if you're listening to
this on a podcast platform then do
please leave us a review on the itunes
store it really helps other people
discover the podcast or if you're
watching this in full hd or 4k on
youtube then you can leave a comment
down below and ask any questions or any
insights or any thoughts about the
episode that would be awesome and if you
enjoyed this episode you might like to
check out this episode here as well
which links in with some of the stuff
that we talked about in the episode so
thanks for watching do hit the subscribe
button if you aren't already and i'll
see you next time bye